hello everyone and welcome to a really
awesome game uh from the penultimate
round of the US Championship 2022
between Samuel 7 and Han smoke and
Neiman and the game itself is really
amazing but what happens during the game
is uh even more amazing it's one of the
weirdest thing to ever happen in a game
especially in the tournament of this
magnitude this is the United States
Championship where uh at at a certain
point in the game uh Samuel Savion uh
literally takes hans's King grabs it of
the board breaks it or breaks his head
you know the little cross on the king
and then it's just you know he he acts
like Hans is the one doing something
weird and then he flings the king onto
the board and I mean I I have no idea
what happened I don't think they've
addressed it after the game uh maybe
they have I haven't seen the interviews
if you guys know what's been happening
there uh do share in the comments but I
will show you a video of this once we
reach that position so stay tuned for
that now Samuel opens with a Ponta D4
now he goes for the Queen's Pawn opening
with Knight to F6 by Hans uh Pawn to C4
and now Pawn to E6 we have Knight to F3
and D5 so just a standard Queen's Gambit
declined with Knight to C3 and now C5
going for the semi tarash C captures on
the five and now uh you could capture e
captures on D5 Knight captures on D5 or
if you wanna have the most fun you will
play C characters on D4 so Queen
captures with e captures on D5 and now
Pawn to E4 we have D captures on e4
Queen character San Diego we have the
early Queen trade King captures and
Knight to G5 now going after Knight
captures on F7 with check the window
Rook here so of course Bishop to E6 and
now Pawn to A3 you could also capture an
E6 but it has been played before nothing
spectacular so upon the A3 Knight B to
D7 and now Bishop to F4 and
interestingly uh Samuel already played
this exact game in this exact tournament
a few rounds before in in his game
against Jeffrey xiong where um continued
with the shot B3 guarding the D1 Square
not allowing Rook to D1 or queen side
castles uh by white but here we have
Rook the C8 and it is now as of move 11
that we have a completely new game so of
course Hans knows about this game and it
wasn't
um
uh hard to to prepare for it as I
imagine he knew that Savion would go for
this it's okay as a move 11 we have a
completely new game we have G3 now
preparing to think after the light score
bishop and Bishop to B3 now guarding
that D1 Square Bishop to G2 and now we
have Knight the H5 going after the
bishop here so Bishop to E3 and now Pawn
to F5
nicely defending the E4 pawn and pawn to
G4 it makes sense to undermine the
structure the Knight doesn't really
belong on H5 and also you want to Black
the capture on G4 so you can start
capturing an E4 so here Pawn to F4 by
hands going after the bishop and now
Bishop to D4 uh the other idea is you
could just trade for example G captures
on H5 F captures an E3 and after I have
captured some like Bishop to C5 and okay
you've won your Pawn back but Hans has a
beautiful development here the Rooks are
doing awesome work the the other will
come into the game so yeah black would
definitely have compensation another
thing you could do instead of Bishop to
D4 you could also capture an A7 but then
F3 is coming and so on so uh Savion not
interested in that A7 Pawn he plays
Bishop to D4 first uh in the now okay
Pawn to F3 just going after the bishop
here G captures an H5 we have F captures
on G2 and the now Rook the G1 we have
Knights the F6 now and Cat factoring the
pawn on G2 solo characters and G2 you do
not want this Pawn surviving at any cost
so Bishop to C5 now defending the pawn
also offering a trade of Bishops and
this is where the game really takes uh a
different turn there are many ways to
continue this game you could capture on
F6 you could capture on C5 and we are
going to explore the two options for
example captures captures Knight
captures here but then Rook to E8 and
now this Rook becomes very active the
bishop pair is fully operational so
maybe not something you want to allow
another thing you could do is play
Bishop captures on C5 go for this trade
and then okay if the Knight moves then
the H5 Pawn is hanging so let's say H6
and then if G captures you're gonna
capture here but again Rook to E8 seems
like a very very nice move okay you can
play F3 defend the Knight it then comes
Rook the F5 goes after the pawn and
still hunts will get a very very
playable position so instead after
Bishop to C5 Samuel plays Rook to D1 and
it's such a such a fine move that you
have to really calculate properly in
order to even try and take advantage of
this if if we can even call it an
imprecision and Hunt just captured The
Rook with Bishop captures on D1
uh so let's see let's see what the Hans
had what Savion had in mind the thing is
you can't go for Knight to F7 check to
Fork the king and the Rook because if
you go for this everything just works in
Black's favor for example King 8 Knight
captures on H eight and now Bishop to F3
now your Rook is hanging your Bishop
here is hanging and let's say Bishop
captures on C5 Bishop captures on G2
Bishop captures an A7 now Knight capture
Sun H5 you don't really get anything for
your exchange sacrifice it's Four Points
each only hunts is our hunts is up in
the exchange so what Samuel had in mind
is Knight the E6 check we have King the
E7 not allowing Rook captures and G7
because now the Knight hangs and now
Knight captures on C5 and this is a move
that maybe uh Samuel missed the bishop
the G4 because it's such a such a
wonderful move uh it seems like okay
maybe you can attack the bishop and then
just grab the G7 Pawn if you can play
this then black will have a very hard
time defending this the problem is if
you try something like this look at this
Rook h.d8 attacks the bishop and okay
Bishop goes back nothing spectacular
still you have to do something about the
bishop and then we capture on G7 but now
B6 the Knight is attacked and what do
you do about the Knight now uh obviously
you have to move it if you move it comes
Rook captures on C3 and that's the the
beauty of it now if Pawn captures Rook
to D1 it's just Checkmate so uh Samuel
has to be very very careful here as
danger lurks everywhere so he plays
Knight captures Knight five captures on
e4 grabbing back the pawn uh Knight
captures an e for Rook G captures uh
Rook captures on G4 Knight captures on
C3 now a nice in between move Rook
captures and G7 King to D6 and now
Bishop captures and C3 and now Samuel is
up to pawns but Hans is up the exchange
but it's very very hard to make use of
that Exchange
since the pawn The Rook here has to stay
guarding the H7 Pawn if you allow
captures then the pass Pawn starts
marching forward the bishop here nicely
controls the queening square so it's
definitely a good trade-off we have Rook
HD 8 by Hans King to F1 and now Rook the
C7 offering a trade of Rooks but of
course not interested Rook to G4 we have
rooked the F7 the F2 Pawn is weak so uh
Hans of course will go after it pawn to
A4 trying to get the pawn all the way to
A5 so everything is nicely defended by
the bishop and now Pawn to B6 hunt
prevents this we have Pawn to H6 and now
Rook to E3 uh preparing to shift the
Rook over to F3 to go after the uh the
pawn here and yeah you don't really also
if Rook to G7 which is a nice move you
can just play Rook to F3 and defend your
Rook while attacking and then uh you
will be very happy so here Rook the D4
check instead King to E6 and now Ponte
A5 trying to uh ruin a Hunt's spawn
structure here Rook eat the F3 going
after the pawn here Rook the D2
defending and now Pawn to B5 not
allowing his Pawn structure to be ruined
Bishop to D for now going after the A7
Pawn now for the moment it's defended
but um
uh still it's a nice diagonal for the
bishop and also the F2 Pawn is not uh
sufficiently defended Rook to D7 and now
just King the G2 attacking the rook and
you don't really gain anything by
attacking the bishop because just Rook T
to check and you move the bishop so
nothing spectacular there so Rook the F5
and now we have Rook to E2 with check
King to D5 and now Bishop to G7 and now
Samuel has a very clear plan of Rook the
E8 Rook dh8 capture the pawn moved the
rook and then Advance the past H Pawn to
Victory so what can Hans do here he
plays King C4 okay Rook to E4 with check
now uh King to B3 and now Rook to E8
going after the pawn here Rook D to F7
attacking the F2 pawn and just Rook the
h8 so he gives up the F2 Pawn in order
to try and take advantage of the
position and now Hans plays Rook to G5
with check interestingly Rook captures
on F2 is a move everyone would play and
it's I mean it's it's pretty much a
nobody trainer but the problem is that
it's winning but you have to be a strong
player like Hans in order not to play it
because sometimes that's just how chess
works sometimes you don't play the
strongest move because you are very
strong but I will just show it because
it's it's such a such a fun line for
example Rook captures an F2 King H3
you're gonna play Rook to F3 check King
to G4 Rook to F4 check King to G3 and
now Rook the C4 and now you will try to
create a mating net for the white king
and of K okay if white wants to have a
chance he has the Capron H7 Rook to D7
now now you see what's happening Rook to
D3 check Rook to see to check Rook to D1
Checkmate the only good way to stop this
is to go back with the king king to G2
and now once you try this Rook the D2
with check there's King the F3 and now
once Rook the D3 check is played you
have King E2 and now okay you can't go
for this because the Rook will be
hanging so Rook the H3 check now white
will try and bring the Rook back into
the game Rook the seat to check now you
will play King the F1 and okay now
there's no Checkmate you have to first
capture the pawn so Rook H capture some
H2 and now King to G1 this is how you
stop Checkmate but only for the moment
as for example Rook the G2 check King to
F1 Rook C to F2 with checking the E1 now
Rook H2 and now just Rook the C8 now
Rook the C3 check might be a problem so
you're gonna play B4 at some point and
now it doesn't really matter what white
plays now the position is winning for
example Rook C7 Rook to F5 and now you
don't even care about the pawn even if
something like Rook captures an A7 the
pawn is defended you're gonna play Rook
to C5 if if white doesn't allow you to
go Rook day five you're gonna play Rook
to C5 and now after King to D1 stopping
this Checkmate now you Checkmate this
way King the A2 and now it doesn't
matter what white plays for example
rookie seven King B1 and there is no
defense against Rook to C1 Checkmate so
it's really a a a wonderful maneuver uh
I mean just one that you you you just uh
have to see but okay in the game Rook
the G5 was played we have King the H3
and now Pawn to B4 this is always going
to be a useful move uh and now King the
H for attacking The Rook Here and Now
Rook the G6 hunts doesn't even go after
the A5 Pawn he first goes Rook to G6 and
now we have Rook captures on H7 but now
all of a sudden Hans abandons the plan
of winning the game and he plays Rook
captures on H6 which basically trades
down into into a drawn end game Rook
captures on H6 Rook captures and G7 and
now Pawn to F4 and this is now a dead
draw if you play at the engine level uh
precise way however of course they are
both humans they are not engines and
mistakes can be made but what makes this
uh position so special is that this is
where the the magic really happens here
in this position
Samuel Simeon picked up hans's King he
he he just grabbed it and he broke it or
maybe he didn't break it maybe the the
little Crown from from the black king
just fell off and then it seemed like he
broke it but then he was just completely
weirded out I'm just gonna show it to
you so you see what happened uh so this
is a a short clip from uh from the from
the game uh watch this
so there we have it that's the position
you can see now it's Hunt's move it's
Hans this time that's that's uh going
down but now Samuel just picks up the
king
and uh the the little Crown gets broken
so he he he he holds the little Crown in
his head and Hans is obviously weirded
out by this he he has no idea what
Samuel is doing and then Samuel just
flings the king to to a completely
random Square uh you don't know what
he's saying but uh it's it's literally
like he's asking Hans does he want to
step outside I mean this is this is
completely crazy now he puts the king
back but Hans stops the clock and he
calls the Arbiter obviously he does not
like what what Samuel is doing he and
the Samuel puts the crown back on the
black king and knock it the Arbiter will
come and then he will uh obviously step
in uh reimburse Hans for for the time
lost that the the blacking spent of the
board I mean this is uh wild stuff so I
have no idea what happened there uh why
did he take it the the first time I saw
the clip I was like um probably Samuel
was so so deep into the game he was uh
you know he wasn't paying attention to
the real world and maybe sometimes you
know when you play a game you just grab
a piece of random piece and then you
just you know start shuffling it you
know through your fingers maybe he
thought that that what what he was doing
uh even though he just grabbed hans's
King from the actual board uh but it
does you know uh you know maybe he was
just trying to send a certain message he
grabbed the king and like broke his head
off I mean like it's uh it can be
interpreted in many ways but as I have
not seen it addressed uh if you guys
know what happened there do share in the
comments so we can all increase our vast
knowledge but okay the game did continue
and even though the position is a draw
like I said it might not be one so King
captures on B2 Ponta F5 Samuel starts
pushing his F Pawn Pawn to B3 hunt
starts pushing the B Pawn we have F6
attacking the rook and now Rook the G2
Hans goes after the H2 pawn and now uh
interestingly there is only one good
move here but it's such a a weird move
to play that you you simply don't play
it and you've seen the situation on the
clock Samuel was down to some six
minutes and Hans has over 30 minutes on
the clock in the game H3 was played
which seems normal the pawn is attacked
you want to push it but this is the move
that cost him the game if you actually
want to draw this you have to play Rook
H5 it's such a silly move to play just
give up the H2 Pawn look at this Rook
captures now King G4 and how are you
stopping the promotion if you put the
Rook on F2 there's a rook to F5 if you
capture on H5 uh it's not a problem King
captures and after King A2 you will also
Queen your pawn and that will be a draw
there's no winning this position so uh
weird as it is uh just uh Pawn to H
through uh Pawn to H3 not not the great
Rook the H5 the move you have to play I
mean uh I mean it makes sense once you
see it of course you want to play Rook
to F5 but in the game H3 was played and
now Hans just plays King the A2 and now
there's a problem how do you start
pushing your uh your pawn it makes sense
to put the Rook on H5 but here you are
just not in time just Rook to F2 I mean
that that that's just not happening so
instead Rook to H7 was played and now we
have Pawn to B2 and here Rook to B7
putting the Rook behind the pass pawn
and interestingly uh it's not as clean
as you might think there is only one
move that wins the game for Hans so uh
you know just for good measure feel free
to pause the video and try to find the
only winning move for Hans while I give
you a couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations on not promoting
that pawn and for those of you who just
want to enjoy the show it is a rook the
G6 this is the only move that wins the
game and Hans did play it now uh
interestingly if if you just play uh
Pawn to B1 Queen uh Rook captures on B1
okay King characters on B1 black is now
up a full Rogue but just King H5 and how
are you stopping the promotion you will
have to play Rook to F2 at some point to
stop the pawn but then you allow the
white king to defend that pawn by King
G7 and then win the black rook and then
white will also be left with a pawn uh
he will Queen it and it will be a race
but but it's a draw so uh it's important
to play the best move here and Hans dots
Rook to G6 now the point is once F7 is
played and there's no other good way to
defend you can play Rook here and if you
play The Rook to F7 then you can no
longer play Pawn to F7 so Samuel does
push it but now Hans just puts the Rook
behind the pass Pawn as one always
should King the G5 now what do you play
well Rook capture percent F7 this is the
only way to do it and that's why Hans
played it now if you capture The Rook
the pawn Queens but if you don't capture
The Rook the pawn Queens just as well so
you might as well capture it so here
Samuel could resign but he will force
Hans the to prove that he can win this
upon the B1 Queen H4 now Samuel does
have a past H Pawn so he will start
pushing it with Queen the G1 check King
H5 now King to B3 now you will have to
win this Pawn at some point
um uh to to to start pushing it that
will be the cleanest way to win so Ponte
is sex with King to C for now uh and
Rook the G7 attacking the queen which is
a nice trick if Hans actually grabs The
Rook it's a stalemate the white King has
no squares so instead after Rook the G7
Queen the C5 with the check Rook the G5
and now Queen to E7 uh Rook to F5 we
have King to D4 and now King to G4 we
have Queen to E6 attacking The Rook now
if you push the pawn then just king
attacks The Rook The Rook is pinned you
will lose that roxo or King the G5 King
to E4 and now Rook to F6 with Queen D7
again trying the same same idea King to
G6 now King the E5 we have rooked F5
with the check King the E6 and now Rook
to F4 and now we have Queen to E8 with
check King to G5 and queen to G8 with
check King to H5 now comes King to E5
attacking The Rook Rook F1 and now Queen
to D5 nicely centralizing and if you
check the black king then the black king
moves and checks the queen checks the
white King on H5 so Rook to f8 Queen to
D1 with check King to G5 and now Queen
to D2 check King H5 Quinta D7 and now we
have Rook Back The Rook back to F1 we
have Queen to B5 now going after the
pawn and now Rook to f8 there's no good
way to uh to actually defend that pawn
if you go you can play
um uh this move here but then many moves
are possible here like for example you
can play King to F5 and then the white
king is completely boxed in and the the
queen covers the F1 Square so you cannot
deliver any checks and white will very
soon get checkmated so instead after
Queen B5 Rook the f8 displayed keeping
that King away from the white king but
not just Queen captures and A6 with King
to G5 now comes Queen to E6 uh Rook to
F1 and now Queen to G8 with check now if
you go uh you can't really go anywhere
you have to go to the H file so here we
have King the H6 but now Queen to AJ
with checking to G5 now Queen to d8
check King to H5 and now Pawn to A5 and
it was in this position on move 78 that
Samuel Savion resigned to the game and
Hans moken Iman gains his third victory
in a row which would be spectacular if
he didn't have such a bad start to the
tournament but uh at least he improved
uh you know uh uh nearing the end of the
tournament so it's a quite a wild game
it was a really really nice exchange
Sacrifice by Savion but Hans played all
the best moves and even though he he
sort of missed that um crazy winning
line that we've shown uh it's good that
he did because otherwise we would never
get to see this uh well actual
decapitation of the black king during a
chess game this is something I mean this
is something you would expect to see in
a bar or maybe uh from from Wilson The
Hustler but you know uh between two two
top Grand Masters playing the United
States Championship I believe this is a
first uh so yeah that's the game hope
you guys enjoyed that regarding the
standings uh if you guys are interested
uh not much has changed Fabiano Corona
still in first place with eight points
Ray Robson following with seven and a
half and uh well it will be it will be
very interesting in the final round
Fabiano faces levonne arunan and Ray
Robson faces Jeffrey xiong so we'll see
and what they can do 8.7 and a half
points with seven we have Dominguez and
one underlying and a whole lot of people
with six and a half so those are the
ones that are are in contention for
first place I would say but yeah
remarkable game remarkable
move by by Samuel just stealing the king
of the board I I love it I hope we see
more of it I hope you guys enjoyed that
as well I would like to wish a very
happy birthday to Jimmy LeBlanc that was
yesterday so uh Happy Birthday again if
you've missed the video and I would like
to thank Anderson Vira torko stanquist
revision reptiles YouTube and Trevor
Terrace for a contribution to my channel
thank you a lot I really appreciate it
as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank you for
watching and I will see you soon
continuing the coverage of everything
that's happening in the Chess World and
uh you know whatever you guys deem
necessary to show use hashtag suggestion
uh thank you all I will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day